[موسيقى] قم
بالبيع في tio من فضلك مع
نفس واحد يقول حسام حايك إنه يستطيع تشخيص
17 مرضًا مختلفًا عندما
نمرض ، التقينا بمركبات كيميائية
وجدنا أن كل مرض له
توقيعه الخاص من التنفس الزفير
يقول الباحثون أن هذا الأنف الإلكتروني  يمكن
شم المؤشرات الحيوية للأمراض ،
يعمل الأنف الإلكتروني كثيرًا مثل أنف الكلب ،
ولكن بدلاً من المستقبلات البيولوجية ،
نضع مستقبلاتنا
الكيميائية وبدلاً من دماغ الكلب ،
نضع جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بنا مع الخوارزميات
التي أظهرناها أنه يمكننا تشخيص
مرض باركنسون الزهايمر
التصلب المتعدد IBD IBS tuberculosis والعديد
من الأمراض الأخرى ، يقول Hayek إن الجهاز
دقيق بنسبة 86 بالمائة ، وهناك المزيد من
الأبحاث التي يجب القيام بها ، ولكن في يوم من الأيام ،
قد يصبح اختبار الرائحة هذا وسيلة أقل تكلفة
وأسرع لتشخيص الأمراض